I started out studying French that was
going to be a French teacher and sports
coach so when I was very young I was
very good at sports I'm like my height
my high school's athletic hall of fame
so I thought that's what I was going to
be and then I started to get tired of
studying languages and I took an
economics course and it was a revelation
so that's what I've been doing ever
since so whatever I tell young people
now is don't think you know what you
want to do because you don't know all
the opportunities that are out there you
have to have a range of experiences
before you choose what you really want
to do and you better choose something
alike because you're going to spend a
lot of time at it if you enjoy it makes
your life a lot easier and more
pleasurable and more satisfying and if
you don't do it